nick margavitches is ready to go to make
his sixth start of the year ninth
overall appearance lead off walk here is
second baseman donovan solano
solidly hit jp ty france they turn to
double play nicely done two outs and it
brings up mike yostrimski
so the breaky ball for strike three mark
averages strikes out yastremski and
that's it for san francisco here in the
top of the first inning on the mound
today for the giants will be tyler
anderson tyler anderson coming into
today's ball game 30 years of age he's
in his
sixth year at the big league level so
crawford
a little flinch there no he got him a
late call we're waiting for that strike
call it never came and then it came
here's kyle lewis
got him swinging on a fastball and
that'll end the inning daryn
right-handed hitter with a 290 average
high fly ball to left
more back
at the wall
out of here
and it's one nothing
pretty impressive by darren ruff just
dropped the bat head down and it was a
soaring
majestic it sort of outlined the
silhouette of
mount diablo wasabi is now in right
field so yostremski's out of the game
one away two on second inning 259 for
tim lopes
it's a job done
that'll blooper hands in front of dubon
seeger waltz is home got a new ball game
at 1-1 rb after tim lopes is 12. now the
mariners have lopes on it first france
out at second base here's philip irvin
hit it hard and it's going to get down
ty france
he comes around marines have a 2-1 lead
throw to third not in time throwing a
second not in time
2-1 mariners
so two runs are in a 2-1 mariner lead
and here's jp crawford
look at that jp going the other way
lopes will score
here comes irvin he scores and the
mariners
have a 4-1 lead in the second inning
here's kyle lewis
so you could see very much that anderson
thought that that was a strike and tyler
anderson just screamed at the home plate
umpire
about that call he thought that was
strike three lewis didn't swing it's a
lead off walk
anderson
unhappy and now he's still he's still
barking and edwin moscoso's saying
knock it off here comes bill miller the
crew chief from his third base umpires
position gabe kepler's coming out maybe
he's been kicked out of the game i
didn't see emotion from the umpire
i think he has been
well obvious how upset tyler is this
throws a wrench in the giants plans here
for this day they're going to have to go
to the bullpen so juani peralta getting
as many pitches as he wants
here's the one-two
and seeger to flores double play
the old adam ball got him
he's gonna lead things off and he's got
a base hit
on the first pitch
he lines a single into left field
get his baton average going that's his
first major league hit go get yourself a
souvenir
a baseball he'll have the rest of his
life and now the bases are loaded with
nobody out so here's longoria
on the ground and a base hit
one run's going to score flores stops at
third and the bases stay loaded it's
four to two so here's crawford who's
rolled out and he's flied out crawford
centerfield moving back as lewis still
moving back he reaches up and he makes
the catch
tagging as flores and dickerson moves to
third great at bat not only does
crawford get the job done to score the
runner but he allows dickerson an
opportunity to get to third base it's
the perfect out
job
pinch hitting here in the seventh tying
run aboard go ahead run at the plate
payoff to belt
struck him out
terence holds on big big out first and
second now former flores to hit her
lined into the gap but nobody's there
we will watch basabe is he going to
score you bet he is and the giants take
the lead is flores is headed to third
with a triple
and wilbur flores inside outs it right
through the gap into triples alley the
giants have come from behind had taken a
5-4 lead dickerson as a pinch hitter in
the six drew a walk
line drive base hit
and that's going to knock in wilmer
flores and the giants add another run at
6-4
the mariners now have seeger on it third
and the tying run is on its second
got him he struck him out with a
fastball to end the inning battering to
walk that's how the mariners have the
tie and runs aboard in between a
strikeout
swing and there's a high fly ball in the
right center
over under it is dubon and he's got it
and the ball game is over
so it wasn't easy but the giants hang on
for a 6-4 win over the mariners in a
sweep of the two-game series